hey klick zoom hey matt Cohen mein name ist
Rico oder besser bekannt hier auf youtube und
starre charlie brown meine frage an dich
ist wie findest du das so viele
leute beim eurovision songcontest 2010 durch deinen song glühen getanzt haben
okay
das war meine frage  Ich wäre sehr
stolz, wenn du die Frage beantwortest und wünsche
dir einen schönen Tag.
Bis bald. Mit freundlichen Grüßen Rico. Ja, was ist los, Charlie? Ja,
was soll ich sagen?
wirklich
glücklich und das ist meine Antwort im Grunde waren
wir wirklich sehr glücklich an diesem Tag
Ich glaube nicht, dass Sie glücklicher sein können Sie
wissen, wie viele wir immer noch so
glücklich sind mit wie wäre es mit diesem Song
und Charlie Brown das nächste Mal, wenn Sie
video nicht
in der
nase bohren, lass ihn am anfang in der nase bohren wie mach es einfach nicht charlie und er
sieht tatsächlich aus wie charlie brown jetzt
verstehe, warum du dich
charlie brown nennst manche sagen gerne,
dass ich aussehe  ike ich weiß nicht hübsch
aussehen wie egal ist
egal okay tut mir leid brah glücklich auferstanden